hey this is presto Walker and you're
watching mind your decisions start out
with a square with a side length of one
draw another square and then draw
another square that connects to both of
these squares finally draw a fourth
square that is attached to this third
square we're going to construct a
triangle
well first draw the diagonal of the
first square and then we'll connect it
to this corner of the fourth square the
question is what is the area of this
triangle I adapted this from a puzzle by
Catriona Shearer who's on twitter at sea
Shearer 41 and I read it on the blog
math with bad drawings can you figure it
out give this problem a try and when
you're ready keep watching the video for
a solution so how can we solve this
problem let's get a different
perspective by rotating the entire
diagram now let's label some of the
lengths the small square has a side
length of 1 and the larger square will
have a side length that's equal to 2 of
these small squares so it'll be equal to
2 the base of the triangle is along this
line now the height will be along the
perpendicular to this line and let's
just create a little rectangular grid
and by doing so we can see that the
height of this triangle is along and
exactly equal to the diagonal of the
square with a side length of 2 so now
let's calculate the base and height of
this triangle the base of this triangle
is the diagonal of a square with a side
length of 1 so it's base will be equal
to the square root of 2 the height of
the triangle is the diagonal of a square
with a side length of 2 so this length
will be 2 times the square root of 2 and
now we
figured out the important dimensions we
need the area of a triangle is equal to
its base times its height all over 2
we've calculated the base and we've
calculated the height and this
simplifies to be equal to 2 and that's
our answer amazingly we can solve this
problem without knowing the height of
the fourth square did you figure it out
thanks for watching this video these
math videos which can be watched for
free on YouTube inspire and build
confidence for people around the world
and they already have over 800 million
views let's share the beauty of
mathematics with your help we can map
the world a better place please
subscribe for free to get the newest
videos watch and share all of mind your
decisions videos you will be a puzzle or
math topic pressure and mind your
decisions calm if you so choose you can
check out my books which are listed in
the video description and you can
support me on patreon for exclusive
rewards thanks for watching and thanks
for your support